all right welcome to this video for some
change here I'll play a bullet
tournament Aeon chess cube and I think
the audio is a bit low while alone
increase it a bit yeah that's a bullet
time tournament one minute so don't take
it too seriously and it's going to start
now okay ace rook first game is one of
them
I guess most dangerous opponents here
yes some with a full set up a black
cannon should be okay can take it
because of Bishop c5 oops so I'm a queen
up for two pieces but the first game is
always difficult for me I usually have
fun time problems c1 is hanging so I can
take down okay all the way back and make
some some room here we're checking a
fall
now lots of stuff is hanging all right
so let's exchange some more
I win some more even better all right
this was a nice start some guys already
have won two games oops
before was the idea really okay it was
enough it just declined the doubling
cube okay game shovel off as I entered
the tournament I hope that's not the
real one at least in terms of winning
this thing
okay a scotch yeah I'm always a couple
of seconds down because of the Ute
rating okay now I'll take it yeah let's
grab all these pawns as long as they're
available for grabbing yeah the rook end
came with two extra pawns and now just
move the King to f5 okay he doesn't mind
the lost pawn again it was lost anyway
so no um nothing he could do really okay
so I'm in the lead with three out of
three pretty good opponent you know I
don't make drawers
okay I play for g4 to prevent him from
playing f5 dumb I don't know what like
black is just playing on the queenside I
don't know what he's doing just before
where does this night go just playing
here be five points apiece next smooth
all right yeah I need to be cautious
this is a bullet tournament I'm somehow
my internal clock on chest cube is
always set for two minutes for those
wall down finals and other stuff and
often need a bit of time to adjust to to
the really quick play all right I'll
just continue developing hmm yeah should
be should be nice here Knight c3 I can
just take here okay I'll grab everything
Queen h4 probably coming okay he's
covered this so let's open the position
okay don't mind the piece should have a
nice attack and I'm also really down on
the clock but really fought a bit too
much here
okay one
it's the idea okay let's just grab this
stuff Queen my queen is also hanging
this is stupid
oops
yeah very silly play and this Queen was
still hanging what the heck am i doing
this was really bad and bullet terms
yeah I got close but I just spent far
too much time on this nonsense at the
beginning she's just taking all the
stuff to took me took me ages
yes some Scandinavian opening yeah he
went for this simple mating idea on edge
to stir I should should have a nice
position okay really it looks rather
risky
a five and so on
yeah the queen is no squares Jeff just
loses the Queen
just open up the position yeah let's
keep it simple all right II lost some
time I'm still ahead but not really in a
bullet mode
yeah just developed pieces we're pinning
and opening the position up I hope to
catch his king in the middle with rook
e8 now cannot cancel attending 9f 295
maybe what's possible not sure yeah this
is a pin nothing special the spin is a
bit a bit annoying for him but still
okay for white okay destroying this
endgame okay five knots it's worse for
me even
I'm probably still okay but no way to
win this on position it is very slow
thankfully okay maybe I can approach
this is nice
how about you will lose some time anyway
okay
still ahead wonder what a stroke is
doing usually is close to the top in
those tournaments it's really quick okay
let's play it okay
he didn't except tomorrow so I'm just a
pawn up oops yeah this can't be good
weakening the the kingside should be a
nice position for white
yeah h5 is hanging so it takes yeah I
can yeah I can take h5 and I cannot play
Queen Queen ch7 ok gives me a rock I can
take on it 7 because of the pin but I
can now bring the rooks into play hero
page 6 and so on and mate alright yeah
it's close its close really almost take
a little too long to bring yeah ok so
given me a pawn here not quite sure for
what exactly
oops I'll take it
no you sorry I certainly just just press
the wrong button get rid of this alright
so again of Scandinavian it was
incredibly popular not sure why really
I'll just develop everything and put it
in the middle centralization is always
good so I won this pawn oops
but he gave me this Bishop also let's
play 46 anchoring the night yeah okay
yeah an extra piece and the mating
attack should be okay Quincy six doesn't
even threaten anything I'm on g6
covering it if he plays Quincy six all
right
two extra pieces should be five to come
try for mating attack
I don't see a mate so let's push the
trip on it's not like it's able to do
much okay this is now made okay
halfway 15 minutes to go okay time to
pay attention those scholars made stuff
and can be can be tricky and bullet all
right so let's grab the pawn is got
Queen h5 okay it's might have been
dangerous h7 and the bishop I want to
play we should reform here we go
should be two now maybe take off the
rock get everything into play here okay
I need to speed up position is just
winning with those extra extra pawns
yeah chief oh I should have taken really
maybe rook age to mate I can go for this
route g3 was made okay yeah this guy is
some very close i stupid I played the
wrong move over here this is really
nothing
okay maybe I can can do something with a
nice night
okay I want to pawn okay
I'd take it okay now I'm nicely
coordinated to get get the rooks on the
seventh no or take it 6m also also fine
yeah okay this is made with h7 I drew
pg7 made all right
so yes so is keeping track here
okay I'll prevent that form no this was
weird
now can't play this [ __ ] bitter quickly
it looks a bit weird to have the bishop
like this yeah this looks all bit
strange I played this not great but now
it's okay again after I got this to to
have form I cannot play d4 c4 as hanging
I hope when does the tech is strong
enough take this let's let's let them
this piece must play on a seven come on
isn't this checkmate no alright so it's
not not too bad this tournament got the
right bullet rhythm at the end still a
tad slow but it's it's okay yes the last
one guy really close to me in the
standings he played for weaker opponents
but it doesn't help yeah this is rather
nice okay I want to prevent d5 this
bishop is not great but can be can be
improved before b5 now
should be a nice square no b7o should be
should be lost really should be five
next yeah it's entropy eight okay
wants to continue only thing is of
course stalemate all right yeah my
average is 200 points higher so I had
the far tougher opposition but impure
points is very close
oops
they are place III this guy didn't okay
in still seems playable
yeah I'm a bit worse here u5 yeah why
did I did I go there okay this is not
too too too terrible taking what the
pawn was much more problematic okay
attack taxi - yeah down on the clock and
somewhat worse not not really great yeah
neat little self oh this is nice we need
two pieces there out of nothing all
right
yeah I'm doing all I can but this guy
also wins all his games against against
a really weak players rating wise maybe
this can be a quick win would be really
really helpful yep yep or some other guy
now just just run ahead of me hard to
believe after this super quick win yeah
but this is some just pressure now
this was really quick but it yeah not
marching again not much I can do and
he's got the longer winning streak it
doesn't help that I had father Beto
opponent's I think I just conceded one
draw I lost I lost I lost one right
again I made this mistake with e3
okay but this is nice
okay let's scrap this just an extra
piece now
come on resign yet things I need some
people to resign actually to still able
to win this yeah this is nice
I still maybe not quick enough we should
see five I want to play and then
everything's on the king okay I'll take
it
queen g4 h3 it's a quicker style okay
yeah I don't win this it's really
nothing I could do with it I'm winning
quickly and don't make too many big
mistakes I think okay this was helpful
really yeah I lost one in one game where
I spent so much time right I remember
now
tween these two looks like a true Muslim
well this is nice
couldn't I didn't have any good
discovery I think better better threaten
this my Bishop to three yeah okay maybe
I have a second chance
yep to play this yeah should have tried
it in some other way this is okay
tournament finished I hope I made it yep
right okay this was was really nice just
lost one game but but I think I won the
rest I think or maybe a draw but not not
much all right
yeah thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed it those bullet stuff is not
really am it's not really something to
learn something about chess but it's fun
to watch I guess yeah thanks and talk to
you soon with new stuff